[Musique]
une fois les vacances ailleurs c'est
descendu à l'hôtel des trois marches non
pourquoi j'en ai raté une à bon alors
vous êtes descendus à l'hôtel de la
plage non je suis descendu à l'hôtel de
la place après je ne connais pas c'est
l'ancien hôtel de la plage mais pour
quand il changer de nom parce qu'ils ont
changé de place à vie mais c'est
toujours un petit hôtel de deux étages
avec ascenseur à ya toujours deux étages
de la censure a disparu depuis quand big
un client appuyer sur le bouton du 6e le
directeur a dû être surpris surtout
qu'elle n'avait pas réglé sa note
voilà ce que j'aime dans les hôtels
français l'imprévu ça dépend des
directeurs ça c'est bien vrai ça tenait
à mettre en une chambre d'hôtel je me
suis réveillée au plafond mais un
tremblement de terre non un changement
de direction
c'est quel hôtel hôtel du parking
l'hôtel du parking oui celui qui a des
chambres et y avait du monde à l'hôtel
de la place je pense radio restants y
avait tellement de monde qu'on nous
donnait fourchette à 8 ans pourquoi
faire à manger plus vite avec y avait un
bon chef
oui mais par des ses plumes c'est plus
un chef indien un iroquois à me disais
comment moi je connais un lave au point
où on mange bien à l'avocat oui il était
comme ils ont moins de travail et son
restaurant
mais qu'est ce qu'on mange dans la vo
poids des purées ou des oeufs battus en
neige c'est bon non monsieur propre et
vous avez une belle chambre à l'hôtel de
la place
franchement bien c'était d'une ancienne
salle de bain comment savez-vous ma
cause du robinet place à la tête du lit
ah bon mais vous aviez une salle de bain
ouais ou ça passe à côté
alors prenez vos bas dans la pièce à
côté non pourquoi n'y ait pas de
baignoire et ependes robinet aucune
équipe android n'est pas couché c'est
ridicule le plat servi dans une chambre
à coucher et mémoire au robinet trouvez
ça normal
enfin après une équipe pas de robinet
dans la salle de bain la question n'est
pas là où est arrivé à ses côtés quel
pied d'un jean marc bouche sur les
robinets chrétiens ordinaire la chambre
à coucher le plan de la salle de bain
pour la chambre à coucher et pourvu
qu'ils avaient un lit on les ya pas de
lit qu'est ce qu'il y avait une
baignoire est prête il une baignoire
dans la chambre à coucher jeu c'était
une ancienne salle de bain donc où
dormir dans le lit de la salle de bain
non dans la baignoire la chambre à
coucher mais où prenez-vous vauban à
l'hôtel des bains ap et vous où ils
voulaient aller en vacances d'un port
tout où êtes-vous descendu à l'hôtel du
berger à combien des toiles une une
prime une grosse arrivée d'un petit
hôtel oui c'est tenus par monsieur
madame le sauveur et leur fils ils sont
trois pour diriger l'hôtel vie c'est le
patron monsieur joseph qui a construit
l'hôtel un bricoleur dans d'anciens
charpentiers
qui fait la cuisine sa femme lamari a et
le fils qu'est ce qui fait le fils b y
sert à table il fait ménage et tout
jeune la trentaine un gars très sympa
avec des choses jusque là une petite
barbe le genre artiste ait peur puces et
les guérisseurs h et il est né le jour
de l'inauguration de l'hôtel dans
l'hôtel non à côté dans une étable entre
un boeuf et une mule un boeuf et une
mule non un homme pardon mais comment se
dit étonné dans une étable barça mystère
en tout cas c'est la nuit de noël la
nuit de noël
oui même que monsieur joseph a pendu la
crémaillère avec des berges et des
environs à héberger parce que l'on de
quoi il ya des moutons alors qu'il ya
des berges à l'héberger n'ont rien donné
aux petits si un mouton haras en plus
beaucoup plus en tout cas il y en a qui
a dit en voyant le petit il est dit
vingt sept enfants voyons j'ai
l'impression que je connais vos hôtelier
c'est pourtant le sauveur ces panneaux
courant il s'appelle le sauveur
joseph et marie le sauveur joseph et
marie le sauveur oui et le fils ils
l'ont baptisé comment marseille lille et
pour baptiser
pourquoi parce que ses parents ne sont
pas croyants
[Musique]